many different right-wing media outlets
and right-wing elected officials
slamming Ron DeSantis decision to
announce his presidential campaign on
Twitter one such critique uh or uh
ridicule came from Fox and Friends Fox
and Friends with a what the heck is
Twitter spaces moment ridiculing
DeSantis for his choice here hey Lucas
so he's
Elon Musk at six o'clock tonight on
Twitter spaces
what the heck is Twitter spaces
I wish I knew more basketball
I think he's trying to make it sounds
like a video function yeah right yeah
I want someone streaming
using social media as a way to announce
a presidency yes it's all very
fascinating so listen there's people
wrote to me and said you know David it's
weird because yesterday morning Fox and
Friends was just gushing about how great
Tim Scott is and now they're making fun
of Ron DeSantis what are the
explanations there's two primary
interpretations of this one
interpretation is that fox sees DeSantis
as the only guy that might defeat Trump
so they attack him and praised Tim Scott
who doesn't have a shot all in reality
in service to helping Trump you attack
the only guy that might beat Trump you
kind of pretend to prop up guys that
have no shot like Tim Scott and it just
keeps Trump at the front that's one
interpretation of what fox fox from
friends is doing second interpretation
is they genuinely want someone other
than Trump but for whatever reason the
brass at Fox News has decided DeSantis
is not the guy we want so we're gonna
make fun DeSantis and it and praised him
Scott uh we we absolutely have no idea
at this point in time Fox News is
priority really
is maintain access to those in power and
that is going to be their primary
motivation we will see in the next
couple of weeks how Fox news's
perspective on the primary solidifies